ancien médecin m'a dit de porter un
masque que je le porte je me pose pas la
question
ok ça s'appelle une approche qu'on
appelle dictatorial aux dictatures
solitaire c'est une manière que qui
n'est pas concevable
parce que quand on parle de pensée
médicale on explique pourquoi quelque
chose on le porte et nous a tant que
règle 119 en tant qu'association nous
avons analysé la problématique des
masques parce qu'il s'agit pas
simplement de se poser la question à
l'extérieur est ce que le masque d'être
portés par les enfants
est-ce que des environs de 6 à 11 ans
dans le porter est ce que le match soit
reporté
quand on fait du sport dans les écoles
est ce que le monstre est vraiment utile
pour se protéger du virus alors je
premièrement il n'existe pas d'études
scientifiques
je vous la firme et je vous l'aurais
terre parce que j'ai déposé la plainte
j'ai épluché quasiment toute la
littérature
il n'y a pas d'étude scientifique qui
dit et affirme le port du masque
scientifiquement parlant va vous
protéger du virus d'abord deuxièmement
vous n'avez pas en une quelconque
manifestation juridique sur les masques
qui puisse dire que le masque vous
protège de l'aco vide et je vous mets au
défi de chercher toutes les boîtes sur
le marché moi je les ai tout acheter
parce que quand on a déposé la plainte
je voulais pas un commettre d'impair et
vous n'avez pas un un une boîte une
comédienne avertissement qui vous dit ah
là là c'est magnifique que vous
éprouviez bien au contraire on dit
attention vous n'êtes pas protégés
contre la copie alors justement c'est ce
que vous direz alors on va on va voir là
la réponse aussi donadille vous allez
continuer votre explosion avoir la
réponse de dan bensadoun sur juste le
masque est ce que c'est ce qu'a dit new
marais il protège pas il ya plein de
gens qui nient ce qui protège pas
complètement
c'est parti c'est la dernière partie
sur ce qu'a dit m carlo alberto brusa
qu'est ce que vous avez à lui répondre
il ya plusieurs gènes sadoun il ya
plusieurs choses déjà ce n'est pas une
dictature quand un médecin propose
impatient de porter le masque de faire
ceci ou de faire cela le médecin pose
une prescription vous savez très bien
qu'une prescription c'est une
recommandation
quand je fais une prescription à mon
cabinet que je vous donne la
prescription vous en faites ce que vous
voulez vous pouvez aller vous faire ce
que vous voulez avec la feuille la jetée
la mâcher ou je ne l'utilisé même chose
pour le masquer vous savez que le masque
à l'origine est une est un outil médical
que les chirurgiens ont pris pour éviter
justement de contaminer les plaies
qu'ils ouvraient les patients qu'ils
ouvraient savez maintenant est ce que
vous seriez rassurez-vous de savoir que
le chirurgien qui vous est opéré de
l'appendicite des amygdales de ce que
vous voulez ne portait pas de masque est
ce que est ce que vous poseriez des
questions donc je vous remercie beaucoup
reprend et pourtant je suis un bon coup
et pourtant le chirurgien je vous
réponds que c'est évident ce que vous
savez il ne paraît pas porter de
l'exclusion
la réalité c'est cette une prescription
médicale c'est la tuerie du consentement
ça veut dire que je dois avoir le droit
de décider de prendre ou de ne pas
prendre de médicaments
donc ce que vous dites c'est magnifique
si on se place et vers une approche
purement médical mais quand c'est un
décret qui même imposer le port du
masque lequel je n'ai aucune explication
ni scientifique ni médicale qui du jour
au lendemain a décidé que les enfants
d'abord ne portait pas près de 600
arbres le porter et je n'ai pas
d'explication c'est n'est pas une
prescription
c'est une décision autoritaire ou
politique qui a pour finalité quoi ce
que le mais ça dit il faut que les un
signe extérieur de viralité
il faut que les gens ce quoi participer
à l'immunité
il faut que les gens participent à une
approche culturelle ce sont les propos
de la messe lui-même c'est quelque chose
de ce qu'elle veut et l'art ce que vous
dites moi je le partage
si c'était une prescription médicale je
le droit commun comme en vaccins comme
n'importe quel médicament soit je le
prends soin je ne prends pas alors que
là nous sommes dans une pseudo théorie
de santé publique qui ne tient pas la
route et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui tu as
même des cons qui sont tous au delà
voiture avec leur masse alors on se
protège pas c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
ce que j'ai fait moi
moi c'est comme un conte avec mon match
dans la voiture je vous le dis